[Musique]
bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour chers on
aime bien et très bien mais qu'ils
auront la chance nous avoir bien
boschker aujourd'hui avec moi alors il
s'agit de josé martinez qui est l'un des
plus brillants
parmi les chefs de la jeune génération
il est né au pays du soleil dans des
pays de soleil il a su choisir ses
maîtres et ses inspirateurs ce qui n'est
pas si facile
parmi les plus grands n'est ce pas vous
avez dit je crois quérard oui j'ai un
drop en lançant de reims voilà un des
très grands noms de la très grande
cuisine française et de la gastronomie
internationale est aujourd'hui il exerce
son immense talent à la maison blanche
qui était resteront à paris avec une vue
exceptionnelle
on ne sait pas ce qu'il faut le plus
admiré le dôme des invalides ou doré la
tour eiffel où les bateaux mouches qui
glissent doucement sur la scène à ses
pieds et il y fait une cuisine sans
cesse renouvelée parce que c'est un chef
qui tout le temps cherche de nouveaux
idée nouveaux mariages de saveurs des
choses absolument exquise vous avez bien
voulu convenir nous retrouver dans les
landes
oui c'est vrai et apprendre une recette
à maïté est-ce que ça va être très
difficile
non parce que je fais pas une cuisine
très difficile donc c'est lisa par
beaucoup de gens qu'est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de lui faire faire qu'est-ce
que venus à une entente de boue
documents que j'adore et ensuite vous
voulez bien faire une recette vous même
qui sera quoi on va faire un confit
d'agneau aux odeurs gym mais tout ça est
assez prometteur comme vous le voyez
alors maintenant et bien josé martinez
il va falloir que vous abandonniez
toutes les deux à la difficile tâche
d'exécuter une de vos recettes et moi à
l'oeuvre à tout à l'heure
à tout à l'heure que vous faut-il pour
cette tarte au boudin au cumin voilà
alors on va faire au fur et à mesure
parce qu'il faut pas grand chose et vous
allez voir c'est vite fait et s'effacer
alors suivez bien suivez le guide
alors là vous avez mis quelque chose
qu'ils veulent dans le troll de 8° me
devis d'olive et de la répu sedo 3
oignons
rentrée pour l'agrément aux oignons que
j'ai coupé mrc et que je vais mettre à
cuire dans mon livre
voilà mais l'a emmené gbc là parce qu'il
faut que ça puisse le tout souvent parce
qu'il faut que l'on dise vous allez lui
m peut-être une pincée de sel voilà là
c'est tout et on va les surveiller
et pendant ce temps qu'est ce que vous
allez faire je vais m'occuper de la fat
quel pack maïté ça c'est pas compliqué
vous allez chez le boulanger vous
demandez un peu de pâte à faire parce
qu'elle contient du nul voila et eux
sarlat faire et d'apparenté dont 2
cuillères à pot prix huile d'olive du
dooly's et puis vous affaiblissez on a
mélangé bière et puis ensuite quelques
hellions et ensuite on va la mettre au
réfrigérateur pour qu'elle durcisse pour
qu'elle refroidisse 5 1
la voilà que les deux côtés on la refera
l'instant ojeda biréacteur voilà qu'est
ce que vous faites maintenant alors
maintenant ouverte
non je vais regarder mes oignons bon
alors mes oignons là maintenant ils sont
jolis je vais contraire voir ce qu'on
fait d'habitude il mettre un peu de
sucre ah ah voilà un petit peu plus là
et je vais les laisser cuire à nouveau
bien falloir attendre maintenant jusqu'à
ce qui donne à l'arrivée c'est très
lorraine voilà j'ai ressenti que du bout
d'herbe
alors qu'est ce que vous en faites de
boudin on va le couper en tranches vous
en fait combien maïté lui est à peu près
un point de vous le graet moi je vais
aller surveiller les oignons à l'avant
je saurai faut oui vous savez que c'est
joli dans la cocotte prévu doublons tout
beau c'est bon alors maintenant
qu'est-ce que vous allez leur ajouter
une veille m 2 juillet depuis hier race
de miel allez-y l'art comme ceci fait
mon boulot au milieu
je vous mets l'envié instable et quand
la côte est chaude ça va un peu
caramélisé cette affaire'' larmes vous
voulez tourner une ère la voilà ça
valait allons maintenant je vais mettre
2 cuillère de vinaigre
eh ben on attend ça aurait pu atteindre
un tout petit peu plus mais il faut le
voir alors là un et deux c'est bon à
l'école puis lula tout hier et
maintenant voilà les allées les jolies
on va le laisser encore un bon moment
pour que ça devienne comme une confiture
que ça devienne blond blanc blanc de
l'homme noël ça va diminuer encore le
double mètre confit d'oignons oui alors
quoi dans ce temps qu'est ce que vous
allez faire je vais m'occuper de
l'appartement a refusé à la pâte
vous l'avez sorti du frigidaire voilà
vous l'avez est allé je l'étalé jeu mais
ont su tailler un joli rond un joli rang
qu'est ce que vous faites main alors
maintenant voir dans la confiture
eh ben dites moi elle a changé ah oui
mais la cuy commet deux temps deux
heures de temps à fait gens de l'ain à
petit feu alors là on va les tables et
ensuite vous laver égoutter dans une
passoire et voilà ce que ça a donné ça
s'appelle la confiture d'oignons très
bien là je vais mettre un des tranches
de boudin
oui que j'ai enlevé la la la peau on a
dû tout à l'heure en rondelles ardennes
et comment ce que vous allez voir
alors je vais mettre ça au fond vous
voulez une plaque à temps de préparer
une voix l'a très bien chaud pendant dix
minutes à peu permis à cette voie là 180
degrés c'est pas ça et maintenant on va
faire la sauce aux sons cubains
c'est une sorte de vinaigrette show
dance exactement qu'est ce que vous avez
mis dedans de lui d'olive de l'échalote
très peu de charlotte un peu d'ail et
maintenant je vais mettre du vinaigre et
du vinaigre et c'était du vinaigre de
kerret vous analysez bien et du cumin
oui voilà que je remue la regarder comme
ça fait joli un petit peu de persil et
je vais juste un an après ma tarte
regardez ça si cet appétissant non mais
l'extraordinaire voilà il n'y a plus
rien à manger et à se régaler alors
c'est parti on va dire bravo le chef
bravo maïté on va demander en tout cas
josé martinez de venir nous rejoindre
maintenant voilà pour un conflit
d'agneau aux aubergines comment allez
vous faire pour cette recette il va nous
falloir une épaule d'agneau un joli non
classe et de l'agneau qui est super
parce que ça doit venir de l'est comme
un acte et a choisi ici voilà il va nous
falloir des zones yongkang a amassé des
aubergines et des tomates
là on va déjà commencer par confire
l'agneau parce que ça demande quand même
à 7 ans oui donc dans une casserole en
fonte pour fait chauffer de l'huile
d'olive ont fait coloré l'épaule qu'on
n'oublie pas d'assaisonner mais parce
que nous nous joignons bien assaisonner
et une fois que les pôles et coloré en
valais tout fait avec tous ses oignons
qui sont amassés m'étouffer avec les
halls 1 mais complètement c'est à dire
qu'on va vous trouverez toutes les pôles
avec ses oignons voilà on va mettre des
aromates c'est à dire du teint on va le
mettre en gros comme ça
qui peut remettre trois quatre feuilles
de laurier sac à main alors dessus de la
libye font de l'aïe
on va couper on peut la laisser en
chemise on l'a coupé en deux c'est pas
gênant voilà les parties les bleus d'en
économiser la cavale de qui ces
sacrements et ça va donner un bon petit
goût à l'épaule et on va recouvrir les
pôles et on va la cuire dans un four à
160 degrés disons un thermostat 5 6
pendant environ une heure et demie tout
dépend de la taille de l'épaule et
pendant ce temps là que fait pendant que
les pôles qu on va faire la sauce tomate
2011 tomates toute simple on va prendre
des désunions qu'on a et émincer on va
les faire revenir dans l'huile d'olive
on va prendre des tomates on va couper
en morceaux sans les éplucher ni les
épépiner c'est pas la peine pas de
gaspillage
non non pour un mail
oui elles sont bien mûr pour une sauce
tomate pour prendre toujours des tomates
qui soit bien mais quand même être un
peu tomates remettre 2 gousses d'ail
coupé en deux on va mettre une feuille
de laurier
il faut qu'on voit là est un petit peu
de temps et bien voilà et on va mettre
bien sûr un peu de sel pour assaisonner
la sauce tomate
voilà beaucoup de pouvoir rejouer n'ont
jamais après bon et fait donc l'appui
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
moi je vais m'occuper de l'aubergine
quand voilà ce que vous en faites
on va la couper en rondelles oui un
petit centimètre disant être exact est
rien
on va couper environ 4 tranches par
personne qu'on va faire frire dans une
poêle on aura mis de l'huile d'olive
voilà alors là les clouds voilà et on
mène les cadres rondelle il faut mettre
assez d'huile parce que l'aubergine
c'est un légume qui pompent pas mal de
matière grasse voilà un peu donc on
assaisonne bien en effet doré on va
aller retirer les paul dufour qui doit
être cuite on va voir
elle est splendide les oignons des voies
plus bas ils ont ils ont fondu dans la
dans la cuisson et puis des polos si
elle a carrément contre le wat a
concentré faveur que faites vous là
alors maintenant on va retirer le plus
d'oignons qui reste qu'on va garder dans
un coin de l'assiette
voilà on va enlever la petite branche de
ta et on va prendre
l'agneau là qui doit être cool on va
prendre mais tout conflit pourra prendre
un morceau et on va les effiloché cette
viande délicatement avec tes droits nous
les a donnés pour s'en sert exactement
non qu'henri viii de moelleuses à qui
s'effiloche très bien très cuite très
confus voilà où là les deux on va
laisser pour les petits chiens
voilà exactement voilà donc en écrira
juste ça par la suite on va mélanger les
oignons la viande
et puis la sauce tomate qu'on a fait
elle est belle elle est belle alors
mettez on va la passer au tamis a les
yeux
voilà pendant que j'ai filage
travaillant dans la casserole je voulais
dans la casserole directement ça va
aller très bien
voilà désormais les mettre de côté
voilà ça y est on écrase bureau et bien
voilà il vous allez tout mélanger les
pros chose et on va mélanger la sauce
tomate les oignons bien les régions qui
est déjà effiloché voilà ça suffit c'est
parfois on sait qu'on aura une belle
couleur oui voilà donc pas tant que la
sauce tomate est passé on avait arrangé
les trois ingrédients et pendant ce
temps aux aubergines continue en cuir
tout doucement doucement
voilà une belle couleur dorée veut
mélanger des trois produits c'est bien
appétissant oui il nous reste plus qu'à
plonger le plat mais avant recuire le
carré d'agneau d'endroits dans une poêle
avec un peu d'huile d'arachide
donc voilà on fait chanter lui on va
mettre le carré à colorer voilà ces
zones est un peu avec du sel et du
poivre
oui va être vite cuit en l'espace de 37
min tit va être cuits et pendant la nuit
on va s'occuper du gâteau d'aubergines
avec le le mélange qu'on a réveillé et
on a rajouté un petit peu de persil
haché dans le mélange voilà on a fait
chauffer tout ça on à rectifier
l'assaisonnement dans un moule
oui un grand renouvellement ricains on
peut le faire dans un grand plat si on
veut on va mettre une tranche
d'aubergine
on va mettre une cuillère des pôles
d'agneaux a confié avec les oignons et
là comme à nyala exactement il aura
remettre une autre tranche d'aubergine
et ainsi de suite jusqu'aux fait un
mille feuilles vertes et de manière peu
timide feuilles de manioc donc une fois
qui est un auteur on va mettre la
dernière couche d'aubergines vous mon
arbre et une fois que le gâteau et fait
donc on peut marquer à plusieurs oui on
va retourner pour ça
sur l'assiette j'espère que ça va se
dérouler normalement ça devrait
ça va me voilà la vérité qui va
retourner la news c'est très bien ou
alors c'est notre côté donc là sur
l'agneau en un peu de chapelure
on va mettre un peu sur la sueur
l'aubergine voilà on y est on va mettre
ça à gratiner dans un four sur position
grille de préférence pour que ça aidera
thing bien vite
et pendant que ça gratte chine on va
sortir d'agneau de la poignée on va lui
couper très bien
le plat est terminé il est joli il est
versé à lyne et admiré l'agneau roséen
parce qu'il est comme il faut la tequila
cuit lagnieu ain a c'est vrai c'est
maïté qui manoeuvrent merci alors encore
plus bravo à tous les deux alors si vous
avez bien suivi
vous pouvez essayer de faire pareil si
vous avez été distrait par la beauté de
ce que vous avez vu faire et bien vous
pouvez aller au restaurant la maison de
l'ange à paris
retrouver josé martinez et sa
merveilleuse cuisine vous en aurez plein
de ressasser la beaucoup d'autres choses
et j'espère que vous reviendrez avec
nous un plaisir merci au revoir à vous
au revoir à tous à très bientôt
merci et au revoir
[Musique]